البدايه اذا بتطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اكد المتحدث باسم القوات
البحريه الاوكرانيه للجزيره تضرر سفينه
انزال روسيه في خليج
نوفروسيسكاروسي لكنه نفى مشاركه القوات
البحريه في هذه العمليه وكانت وكاله
رويترز قد نقلت عن مصدر امنيا اوكراني
قوله ان جهاز الامن الاوكراني نفذ
بالاشتراك مع القوات البحريه الاوكرانيه
عمليه استهدفت سفينه انزال روسيه بزورق
مسير يحمل نحو نصف طن من المتفجرات حول
هذه التطورات ينضم الينا من دونسك مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين ناد غير ومن اوديسا
عامر لافي ارحب بكما وابدا مع لافي
والروايه الاوكرانيه لما جرى عمر
نعم ازدهار يعني هذا اليوم وفقا للاعلام
الاوكراني والمسؤولين الاوكرانيين هناك
حدثان او استهدافان الاول في شبه جزيره
القرم في فوديسيا بخصوص طبعا روايتان
مختلفتان لان المكانين مختلفين بخصوص
استهداف شبه جزيره القرم معظم التصريحات
الاوكرانيه الرسميه تحدثت عن ان هذا
المكان هو هدف مشروع بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
فشبه جزيره القرم هي مكان محتل من قبل
القوات الروسيه الامر الاخر هذا المكان
الذي استهدف اليوم يحتوي على مخازن وقود
واماكن لمخازن الدعم اللوجستين الاسطول
الروسي وبالتالي هي اهداف مشروعه بل وتوعد
كثير من المسؤولين الاوكرانيين الذين
تناولوا هذا الموضوع باستمرار مثل هذا
الاستهداف لكن الاستاذ الاستهداف الاخر في
نوفو روسيس يختلف الوضع بخصوص هذا المكان
لماذا ازدهار لان هذا المكان واراضي روسيه
وعاده اعتدنا ان يوم الق والمسؤولين
الاوكرانيين بان اوكرانيا لها ضلع فيما
حدث لكنهم يحاولون الابتعاد قدر الامكان
عن اتهام او الاعتراف رسميا بانهم وراء
هذا الاستهداف بخصوص الاعلام هنا هناك
ترحيب كبير مناقشه كبيره يصفون مجره
بخساره كبيره لروسيا نتحدثون عن ان هذه
سفينه الانزال هي سفينه كبيره عملاقه كانت
روسيا قد جلبتها من الاصول الشمالي هي لا
تتبع اسطوري البحر الاسود ولكن جلبت في
بدايه الحرب لتشارك في حصار اوديسا وحصار
البحر في اوكرانيا البحر الاسود
وللمشاركه في عمليات الانزال التي كانت
مفترضه على هذه المدينه مدينه اوديس
وبالتالي يعتبرونها خساره كبيره تصريحات
رسميه تقول بان اجسام مجهوله هي التي
استهدفت يتحدثون على سبيل المثال مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني قال بان المسيرات قد
غيرت قواعد اللعبه
يتحدث بان ما جرى سينهي استفزاز روسيا في
البحر الاسود وسيعيد قواعد اللعبه وسيعيد
القواعد الملاحه العالميه الى طبيعتها قبل
ان تسيطر عليها روسيا ايضا المتحدث باسم
المخابرات الاوكرانيه اندريه يوسف قال
ايضا في هذا الاطار بان من الان وصاعدا
روسيا ستحسب حساب احتمال تكرار مثل هذه
العمليات التي وصفها بالبرمائيه اذا هناك
ايماء لكن على المستوى الرسمي ما زال
الاوكرانيون ينفون نفيا قاطعا اي مشاركه
لهم واليوم المتحدث باسم البحريه
الاوكرانيه في حديث خاص للجزيره قال لنا
بان انه بان القوات البحريه ليس لها اي
مشاركه في استهداف هذه السفينه الانزال
فلنستمع لما قال
لسنا منخرطين في الحاق اي ضرر بهذه
السفينه في البحر الاسود واوكرانيا لا
تستهدف اي سفن مدنيه او اي موانئ مدنيه
حتى لو كانت تحت الاحتلال ونحن نعمل على
الدفاع عن موانئنا ضد الهجمات الروسيه
ابقى معنا عمر لافي ولكن ماذا تقول
الروايه الروسيه في ذات الملف نور
نعم ازدهار الروايه الروسيه لم تتغير ولا
تزال على حالها فعلا هي اكدت ان هناك
هجوما تعرضت له احدى الموانع
الروسيه في البحر الاسود بكل تاكيد هنا
الاتهام الروسي هو اتهام مباشر
لاوكرانيا بانها هي من تقف وراء هذا
الحديث لكن هناك شيء اهم حينما يتحدث
الروس دائما يتحدثون عن فشل مثل هذه
العمليات وانها لم تحقق ما تريده سواء على
مستوى الموانئ الروسيه او على مستوى شبه
جزيره القرم الحديث هنا على ان جميع هذه
المسيرات سواء منها المسيرات المائيه او
سواء منها المسيرات الجويه تقول روسيا
بانها اسقطت كل هذه الهجمات بالمنطق
العسكري لحد الساعه لا تزال روسيا تتعامل
مع هذا النوع من الهجمات على انه تهديد
لكنه ليس بالخطير باعتبار انها تقول بان
دفاعاتها بشقيه سواء منه الدفاع الجوي
سواء منه الدفاع الالكتروني لا يزال قادرا
على صد هذه الهجمات والمسيرات لا تصل بحد
ذاتها الى الاهداف المرسومه لها وبكل
تاكيد هنا الكلام الروسي انها لحد الساعه
تستطيع ان تضبط ايقاع المواجهه مع
اوكرانيا لكن بكل تاكيد التفكير العسكري
الروسي الان قد يتحدث عن رد هذه الهجمات
ورد مراكز التي تنطلق منها هذه الهزمات
باعتبار ان منطقه البحر الاسود هي منطقه
استراتيجيه بالنسبه لروسيا وتريد ان تفرض
فيها سيطرتها وتكون صاحبه القول الفصل في
هذا المجال سواء على المستوى العسكري او
على المستوى التجاري لذلك الحديث ربما قد
يتركز مستقبلا او خلال الساعات القادمه
على اهداف روسيه سواء من خلال استعمال
الصواريخ المجنحه او المسيرات باستهداف
مواقع من تصفها او تتهمها روسيا بانها
مواقع الانطلاق سواء في اوديسا سواء على
مستوى الامتداد الجغرافي في الجنوب في
واجهه الجنوب او الشمال الغربي في اتجاه
في اتجاه السومي لكن بكل تاكيد ازدهار
هاته المواجهات التي يمكن ان نصفها
بالمواجهات الاستراتيجيه على مستوى الجو
ما بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه
قد تعكس كذلك طبيعه وسخونه المواجهه على
مستوى الارض وعلى مستوى الجبهات هنا نتحدث
بالتحديد عن الزياره التي قام بها وزير
وزير الدفاع الروسي شويغو اليوم الى الى
الاداره العمليات في قوات المركز والتي
ربما يبني من خلالها الاستراتيجيه المقبله
في المواجهه وهي التقدم وضرب المواقع
المتقدمه للقوات الاوكرانيه وهو ربما ما
حدث ما حدث اليوم سواء بجبه الجنوبولوجيا
وخرسون وكذلك بجامعه الشمال والشمال
الغربي وهو ما تحدثت عنه وزاره الدفاع عن
قضيه مواجهه الاجسام الطائره وعن قضيه سد
الهجمات الاوكرانيه والتقدم على مستوى
الارض وهذا ما سنستمع اليه في التصريح
لوزاره الدفاع والمتحدث باسمها
القوات الاوكرانيه كما استهدفت مراكزها
للقوات الاوكرانيه والمعدات العسكريه في
142 منطقه ودمرت مستودعات الوقود والذخيره
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مناطق بالدونيه
الدفاع الجوي الروسيه 15 صاروخا من طراز
واسقطت 28 مسيره اوكرانيه في مناطق
العمليات العسكريه
شكرا اذا للزملاء عامر لافي من اوديسا
ونريد غير كان معنا من دونات